we've received reports from the JTF
indicating lmb movement in the warren
gate water treatment plant HQ are
pushing to bomb the site but this plant
is vital for the recovery of new york
valcon squad was sent to scout the area
but they've gone dark
stop the lmb before it's too late this
is your first incursion Falcon lost
incursions of deadly missions requiring
cooperation preparation and a high
degree of skill find the right strategy
to destroy the strongest enemies and be
rewarded with the best flute
Falcon lost and future incursions will
introduce new exotic weapons and
top-of-the-line gear sets combined parts
of the same gear set to unlock powerful
effects each gear set is adapted to a
different gameplay style
and this update will add the possibility
to exchange loot with members of your
group and to take on daily weekly
assignments straight from Division
command
strategic homeland defense is also
sending a central air drops directly in
the dark zone to assist division agents
these drops are not contaminated so
you'll want to be the first to put your
hands on them
my dr name
get three major expansions and exclusive
bonuses with the season pass